let's draw ourselves a triangle
okay let's this side has length six
let's say this side right over here has
length ten and let's say that this side
right over here has length X and what
I'm going to think about is how large or
how small that sawed that value X can be
how large or small can this side be so
the first question is how small can it
get well if we want to make this small
we would just literally have to look at
this angle right over here so let me
take look at this angle and make it
smaller so let's try to make that angle
as small as possible so we have our 10
side we have our 10 side actually let me
do it down here so you have your 10 side
the side of length 10 and I'm going to
make this angle really really really
small approaching 0 if that angle
becomes 0 we end up with a degenerate we
end up with a degenerate triangle
essentially becomes one dimension we
lose our two dimensionality there but as
we approach 0 this side starts to
coincide or get closer and closer to the
10 side and you could imagine the case
where it actually coincides with it and
you actually get the degenerate you get
so if you want this point right over
here to get as close as possible to that
point over there essentially minimizing
your distance X the closest ways if you
make the angle all the way equal to 0
all the way so you know let's actually
let me draw a progression so now the
angle is getting smaller these angle is
getting smaller this is length 6 X is
getting smaller X is getting smaller
though we keep making that angle smaller
and smaller smaller all the way until we
get a degenerate triangle so let me draw
that pink side so you have the side of
length 10 now the angle is essentially 0
this angle that we care about so the
side is length 6 side of length 6 and so
what is the distance between this point
and this point and that distance is
length X so in the degenerate case this
length right over here is X we know that
6 plus X is going to be equal to 10 so
in this degenerate case X is going to be
equal to
four so if you want this to be a real
triangle at x equals four you've got
these points as close as possible it's
degenerate into a line into a line
segment if you want this to be a
triangle X has to be greater than four
now let's think about it the other way
how large can X be well to think about
larger and larger X's we need to make
this angle we need to make this angle
bigger so let's try to do that so let's
draw my 10 side again so this is my 10
side 10 side I'm going to make that
angle bigger and bigger and so now let
me make take my six side and put it like
that and so now our angle is getting
bigger and bigger and bigger it's
approaching its approaching 180 degrees
at 180 degrees our triangle once again
will return into a line segment it will
become a degenerate triangle so let me
draw the side of length X try to draw it
straight so we're trying to maximize it
to that point and that point so this is
side of length x and let's go all the
way to the degenerate case at the
degenerate case and 180 degrees the side
of length six forms a straight line with
the side of length 10 and this is how
you can get this point and that point
point as far apart as possible
well in this situation what is the
distance between that point and that
point which is the distance which is
going to be our X well in this situation
X is going to be 6 plus 10 is 16 if X is
16 we have a degenerate triangle if we
don't want to degenerate triangle if we
want to have two dimensions to the
triangle then X is going to have to be
less than 16 now the whole principle
that we're working on right over here is
called the triangle inequality theorem
and it's a pretty basic idea that any
one side of a triangle has to be less if
you don't want to degenerate triangle
than the sum of the other two sides so
length length of a side has to be less
than the sum of the lengths sum of
lengths of other two sides of other two
sides if you're willing to deal with
degenerate triangles where you
essentially form a line
you lose all your dimensionality you
turn to a one-dimensional figure then
you could say less than or equal but
we're just going to stick to non
degenerate triangle so the length of a
side has to be less than the sum of the
lengths of the other two sides and just
using this principle we could have come
up with the same exact conclusion you
could say well look X is one of the
sides it has to be less than the sum of
the lengths of the other two sides so it
has to be less than 6 plus 10 6 plus 10
or X has to be less than 16 X has to be
less than 16 the exact same result we'd
got by visualizing it like this if you
want to say how large can X be well you
could say well 10 has to be less than
you could say 10 10 has to be less let
me do or how small can X be you have to
say 10 has to be less than 10 has to be
less than 6 plus X the sum of the
lengths of the other two sides if you
subtract 6 from both sides right over
here you get you get 4 is less than X or
X is greater than 4 so this is a in some
level it's a kind of a basic idea but
it's something that you'll see
definitely in geometry and then you'll
go far into other types of mathematics
and you'll see other versions of what's
essentially this triangle inequality
theorem